you are a child's play thing
you are a sad strange little man you can
compare the toys okay
you know this is uh this is like this is
one of these kind of toys that
essentially illustrate the fact that
civilization as we know it is coming to
an end
you know you know the apocalypse is upon
us when this
is entertainment yeah yeah yeah
you're flying this isn't blind this is
falling
with style i won't even start with the
way this guy
is built okay what's he what's he got
inside there
i took this and played with it four
minutes and did the same thing got the
button stuck in there
oh shut up bye played his helmet
followed wait a minute
there's a little lisp there buzz and
there seems to be no sign of intelligent
life anywhere
hello hey whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa did i
frighten you
those are fine look at that they're
vintage kind of like
western wear dungarees the body of woody
was actually modeled after
tom hanks's body so that's exactly what
they think
yes this is exactly what tom's body
looks like good looking in slacks huh
not there tom's a handsome man not a
bright guy but a handsome guy
buzz looking alien
[Laughter]
my problem was you know my daughter goes
where where'd the buzz light your dog go
it's sitting next to my bed now
i have it on my nightstand i just uh you
know i just want to look at myself a
little bit more
buzz will you get up here and give me a
hand
when i first saw the first one i went
and i saw buzz the first scene i saw was
me
you're mocking me aren't you i cracked
up i said this is really funny
i've set my laser from stun to kill god
great
great yeah and if anyone attacks us we
can blink them to death
woody is so volatile he yells a lot so
that you know my vocal cords would be in
shreds after a while and my diaphragm
would be stretched out
i made movies where i'd carried guys
through the jungle you know
for weeks at a time and i've never been
as tired as i am right now
i'm exhausted don't you get it you see
the hats
i am mrs nesbitt
snap out of it
i've talked to my five-year-old about
going to see it and i you know i've
explained it you know
he's just thrilled right there's a
picture of woody and buzz
in in in in newsweek magazine i said hey
buddy that's uh that's me
and he was just like study dad this is
not you no my voice is that and he was
looking he was utterly fascinated by a
by a still of it and you guys had young
kids
back then when the first one was
introduced do they still
love your roles that you played are they
still
huge fans of these they are uh we were
at disney
land we were say there's there's a
there's a night leave there's a
fantastic what is it fantasy in the sky
kind of thing and it closes with every
disney character in history
dancing on the mark twain steamboat as
it goes around
tom sawyer's island and there is mickey
and donald and daisy they're all there
pluto
peter pan captain hook all the
princesses and there was buzz and woody
as well
dancing on the back and my daughter who
was in her 30s burst into tears because
she realized that some version of her
dad
is going to be at disneyland for the
rest of eternity and that so i they you
know you
you you don't discount that that's a
powerful thing
hey wow what what is it buzz
oh great you found them where were they
here in the car see
now what'd i tell you right where you
left them